show us your head show us your hands now  what a dude  i got an appointment for 10 30.  yeah  what's up i got an appointment for 10  30. okay  yeah  yeah okay  inside for their photo ids i just made  it by yourself yeah okay  all right next form is our rental  contract just makes you responsible for  the jet ski you will rent for muscle  gain any damage to it damage can't  happen as long as you but everything  that we do but we do  finally life jacket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh  get away go  before he gets on the jet skis  all right they're right underneath  okay we're coming up  now right here  show us your hand show us your hands now  show us your hands now  show us your hands in the orange life  vest  your hand  drop the phone  drop the phone get off the ground  get on the ground  get away from him get away from our  deputies get away  get away  go over here  [Music]  y'all know my name y'all  [Music]  you